well kevin what a historic night this is
the first time that football fans could
be here inside a legion stadium
due to cover 19 restrictions only about
2 000 of the 65 thousand seats were
filled
and even though that's the case even
though the rebels lost unlv fans tell us
they were just thrilled to be here it
was really
pretty neat it didn't seem like you're
in las vegas it seemed like we went out
of town to go see a pro football game or
something is it beautiful
just a beautiful stadium he was more
amazing than i thought it would be
it was really first class and right up
there with vegas
from what i saw it was about the safest
place i've been in the last eight months
you heard it there people feeling safe
definitely a fun night for everyone some
fans we spoke to actually said
that they hope that the capacity limit
will be even more so
we'll see if that changes in the future
but really a really exciting night for
football fans here at legion stadium
john we're going to toss it back to you
in the studio